[Music]
as the border crisis has intensified
more anchors reporters and commentators
are speaking out
against president biden's stance of not
allowing journalists to visit
the overcrowded texas facilities
blocking access to the news media is not
leveling with the american people mr
president
the biden administration kept talking
about transparency and we're not getting
any transparency here
with what is happening at the border and
nbc's kristin walker challenged the
president at that first news conference
will you commit to allowing journalists
to have
access to the facilities that are
overcrowded moving forward
i will commit when my plan very shortly
is underway to let you have access to
not just them but
other facilities as well but guy the
president didn't agree to a timetable
neither did
jen saki on fox news sunday this morning
i can't reach any other conclusion other
than the biden team knows the media are
heavily focused on this border crisis
and don't want pictures that would fuel
especially the television coverage
well it's completely unacceptable and i
think if the exact same thing were
happening during the trump
administration with these same
restrictions on the press
the explosion of fury within the media
would be a lot louder than it is i'm
glad we're hearing something about it we
should hear a lot more
the biden administration created this
crisis they're sort of denying the
crisis
while blocking access to the press to
document the crisis
first hand there's an nbc news report
that they're not allowing ride-alongs
for reporters at the border they're
saying
direct all questions to washington don't
talk to journalists down there
they're calling it a gag order at the
border on top of the lack of access to
the facilities
the kids in cages as the democrats would
call them it's
outrageous well liz the white house did
allow
nbc reporter gabe gutierrez let's put up
some of the footage that
his crew shot to go to an hhs
facility a nice one with soccer field
not as overcrowded
but not the border patrol facilities
that are badly overcrowded
let's hear a little bit from his report
the children we saw today were calm and
they seem to be in good spirits but
this issue is about much more than just
this one hhs
facility so he knew what was going on do
you think it's the growing media
pressure though that
kind of prompted the white house at
least to allow one reporter access to
one facility
well yes but in and of itself that's
ridiculous
guy is absolutely right you know the
biden administration
was supposed to turn the page on what
president trump was heavily criticized
for
and that was no transparency they were
supposed to be transparent and then the
first move they make
is to be non-transparent it is
ridiculous it's outrageous and this is
starting to get a lot of attention
and traction with the media and as you
can see you know whether it was nbc or
cecilia vega on abc
where she had her facts and numbers and
she pushed him hard and at one point he
said
is that a real question you know he he
bristled we've seen president trump
wrestle certainly
they do that but the fact is that the
press is now pushing hard and they
absolutely should
biden is very very vulnerable to
criticism here
right that's cecilia vega from abc she
had talked about to talk
interviewing a nine-year-old honduras
boy he would walk from his home country
to the border and i thought that was one
standout moment again we'll talk about
the pressure later
you talked about president trump who
certainly got
lots of moral condemnation guy from the
press over his treatment of migrant
families especially separating families
but even knowing they were going to get
beat up over it the trump administration
did allow journalists
access to these facilities
yeah the transparency was much better
actually during the previous
administration on this front
and i would say the family separation
policy was a disaster politically and
on a humanitarian basis but that was
short-lived
a lot of the future policies beyond that
that actually helped clean up the mess
down there and mitigate a lot of the
struggle
those were immediately swept aside by
team biden
leading to the current crisis that we
have and again they're actively trying
to cover it up and it's just it's
astonishing that president biden was
asked about this can you commit to
transparency
he said well yes eventually they said
when he said i don't know
how is that an acceptable answer of
course it's not
liz uh axios obtained some pictures of
border facilities from that have been
leaked to democratic
congressman henry cuellar and once that
happened i think it's pretty clear
that the media are going to get these
images one way or another and the white
house must know
it's losing control of the narrative
here and can't just say
this is you know just a small problem uh
that we are
dealing with well they let gabe go in
from nbc
and and they brought him to i mean a
model
facility yes really happening here
and and you know president trump going
back to he was
highly critical of the press but this is
where the press
shines freedom of the press get that
sunshine in there
blast in the lights and the cameras and
the action and you see what's going on
and the press will find out
and there should be respect for for them
and for anybody who's trying to get in
there and see the true story
you can't just sit there and say i'll
let you guys in when the optics look
better where we can clean things up
this is a humanitarian crisis obviously
and the press needs to be
very very hard and press and continue on
that and we have a moment of consensus
here and i think even the mainstream
media
are united that this is not acceptable
as guy put it guy benson liz claiman
great discussion thanks very much for
joining us this sunday